he came in on fire the governor of the
great state of Ohio John Kasich here the
Republican presidential candidate came
in started shooting hoops got on the
golf simulator had a couple of nice
pitching weds par-3 7th at Pebble this
is fun you should have you should have
this you know in Washington DC how do
you know I don't now you were talking a
pretty good game there with basketball
well look you know we used to play the
Congressional basketball game it was
really fun and actually they were good
players a lot of them played in college
so we played against Macmillan after he
had a triple-double in the NBA the year
before and we ended up beating him
selected Rozelle was the announcer and
he selected me as the MVP it was one of
the greatest moments of my lifetime
McMillan plated Maryland went to the NBA
611 a really good player yeah he was a
grazing wonderful guy too but we used to
play you know is one thing we used to do
in Washington is we play we play ball at
four o'clock every day knock each other
around Republicans Democrats we got
along we had a lot of fun and once a
year we played that basketball game we
play a baseball game too and that was
always a lot of fun you know the coach
was a guy named Silvio Conti from
Massachusetts and he did he left me he
kept me on the bench for two or three
years and then somebody got hurt I
played shortstop I went for four five no
errors in the field
I got named MVP and they asked Conti
well you're such a judge of talent why
didn't you play the kid he said well I
didn't want to bring him along too fast
by you know sports is great I just love
it and you know people say you watch
like News and all that and I saw watch
the Golf Channel i watch you know watch
ESPN i I have the bleacher report on my
iPad I mean I love sports you know but
how important is a sports background in
being in politics I don't know about
that Dan I mean you don't want to be a
nerd I mean if you a sports person
you're gonna be a pretty regular guy as
a competition was a kid we used to
that's all we did was play ball play
baseball play basketball up at the
schoolyard it was a magical time because
there were enough kids to really be able
to play with a you know full teams and
all that and so you know we
we a lot of time we didn't have a right
fielder so when somebody would hit it to
the right of second base we'd spend at
half an hour yelling and screaming to
each other about whether it was fair or
foul and that's where I kind of learned
how to argue it's when I learned about
competition I was always smaller than
everybody else so I had a you know
really work at it is it's great and
Sports's is just fantastic and you know
what can I say
so I fall a lot of it you know I've been
following the Masters of course I've
been amazed at Spieth and what he did
yesterday but would you rather be did
you want to be a politician or an
athlete growing up no I never thought I
would be an athlete I don't you know I
wanted to be a lawyer just one thing
kind of led to another and you know
things happen it kind of worked out one
foot in front of the other but I just I
love I just love to follow it it's like
so relaxing to me you know I'm so mad
that the Masters isn't on at this point
I woke up this morning I tried to put it
on you get these little snippets on the
news and that's about it
have you played Augusta yes yeah how'd
you do well I'm kinda like bragging now
okay the people are tired of this right
my staff is here and they're like what
are they rolling their eyes I tell you
the first time I went I went twice I've
been invited again but I just haven't
gone back but the first time I went I we
they used to have a kind of an old Dan
an old practice range and they've redone
the whole thing but when we were there
the first time you know I told me the
caddies bet on you they watch you swing
on the practice range and then they lay
down bets so we got to the 18th hole and
I forgot I mean up until that point I'd
forgot about the betting so I hit my
ball out by the sand trap on the left
now today I think you have to hit that
three hundred yards but we were playing
the members tees and I remember I was a
hundred and fifty five yards from the
from the pin I told the caddie to give
me a 7-iron he said no you need to hit a
six and we argued back and forth and
finally I remembered hey they bet on you
so I said okay give me the six so I hit
the six and knocked it in a hole for a
two so you got an eagle on 18 yeah and I
looked at the Caddy and I said I told
you it was the six yeah it was a great
it was really remarkable I got traded on
the first tee by the cab yes I didn't
realize
play too much there twice but my caddy
had my clubs
and next thing I know the other the
other caddies got my clubs I said what
just happened he said I traded for you
so and but the experience was great well
no you have such a great job and with
such a great crew and I wish everybody
could see your studio so how did all
this happen for you how did it all start
do a do when you were a kid or how did
this all happen I wanted to be in sports
but I didn't know how to be in sports
but I just started consuming as much
sports as possible trivia I wanted to be
prepared if I ever got the opportunity
and you know you may not look the right
way or may not sound the right way but I
wanted to have the knowledge there if I
was ever you know got the opportunity to
do it so I I did some radio and then got
into TV went CNN then from CNN I went to
ESPN and spent 18 years there and then
decided that I wanted to do it on my own
terms with my own guys and you know we
just did it in a man cave there so I was
lucky but the 18 years at ESPN helped me
prepare for know where I smelled out
there yeah yes although you walked in
and you started railing against ESPN
with me and bill said no the only thing
that I've been yeah I've been asking the
question because it seems as though they
got a pretty heavy hand that's what it
seemed to me I mean we're all fans of
ESPN because you know I mean it's 24
hours it's cool it's fun of course we
all love the commercials and you know
the commercial broadcast for ESPN
they're clever but I I was I just didn't
know what the make of the whole Simmons
thing it's like there's a war there and
I didn't understand what it was and
you're not there anymore and I just
can't figure it out if they just like if
you cross them you know they like pounds
you I I don't know I don't know what to
think about it well I think that boy do
I want to get into this well you brought
it up well no you brought it up when you
want to I know but then you brought it
up on the air I mean no I was saying to
my guys do I want to hang this up
because I always walk down this road
well then maybe you should not a yellow
brick road
I think that it's it's like most
companies they want total control but
bill simmons wanted total configure of
the content yeah of everything yes so
like you you get to it's a tug of war so
you know I was at Fox for nine years and
I was on the air at Fox News and they
never bothered me with content I mean
they would give me segments to do but
they never really would tell me how to
do them never so you're saying that you
would want us to do certain things and
they didn't want you to do them and you
struggle for independence that's
understandable yeah I I think it got to
the point where they had outgrown me or
I'd outgrown them and you know I don't
know I think the same with Bill Simmons
what makes what makes for a brilliant
you're supposed to be interviewing me
but I want to interview you know this is
interesting to me what makes for a
brilliant sports analyst you know what
what is it that makes you or Simmons who
would you else would you put up
I mean you are and so so as Simmons who
else would you say would be up there and
what makes you guys what you are is it
is it a different take on things what is
it I think you have to be curious and
you have to question and you have to
listen when you have people on and I
think that you'll learn an awful lot
that way I think you have to be fearless
at times I think you have to be willing
to put yourself out there I don't think
it's any different than a politician
that you have to be able to take a stand
back up your stand and you're gonna have
people coming at you from all arrows or
angles with you know slings and arrows
in and in and if you're willing to put
yourself out there I think the audience
wants you to have an opinion and they
respect that Dan who would the athletes
over I can't even imagine how many youth
you met who would you put up and you
know kind of the top of people that you
found really fascinating athletes that
you were like wow now that's there that
person's in their own class I think the
guy who's honest because we would stand
out for you
Berkeley has always been honest with me
yeah Dale Earnhardt jr. has been honest
with you know that's an interesting
story because you know a lot of times I
mean with his father right like the
greatest guy ever you know is
interesting he I would have thought that
he had the most NASCAR wins but he's not
even close to it but he generated the
what the the
spirit of the whole sport and then you
would have thought well jr. you know can
jr. really you know I mean he's jr.
right but this guy has been terrific
hasn't he great for this sport
and imagine going back to the scene of
where your dad died and he does that
twice a year Daytona hundreds of laps
and you're going by where your father
died and to be able to talk about that
is I'm always I marvel whenever jr.
brings it up I don't know if I could do
that I go by where my dad died and I do
that twice a year at races so he's just
been honest about the most personal
thing to him is his father dying and I I
don't I don't want to waste the
audience's time if you're tuning in or
staying in your car I want you to stay
five minutes later and be late for work
because I'm gonna give you so yeah
that's really cool let me and it's
interesting you know I'm sitting here
thinking why is it that people are so
drawn to this I think it's um it's human
excellence isn't it and and foibles at
times you know the guy that you know
bump bounces the ball out of bounds or
the you know what I think is a really
terrible story now and I don't know what
to make of it is is this theory of
sharapova you know I can't figure out if
she did something wrong I mean is this
was this and it was this at a
performance enhancement drug or was this
a medical thing what was the story now
she's used it for a long time right but
they changed the rule did she you think
I'm gonna guess well they're all there's
a list of things that you can't take now
whether she didn't click on it as she
said and look at the list that's on
there then that's her fault they're
viewing it as a performance-enhancing
drug so you had the opportunity that
gave you the information if you you know
chose to ignore it or you know you just
missed it you still have to pay the
price I don't know how heavy the price
is but it's already been having a lot of
these sponsors surprise I know let me
ask you can I take a break yeah yeah
sure of course and pay for this yes I do
yes and it's expensive I gotta pay for
all these Secret Service guys around
here and your coffee that I got you and
if you want to shoot hoops during the
break you can or you want to we're gonna
talk you want to go the golf simulator
you're not agree hit it on the grill
okay okay all right fair enough all
right
so we'll talk to the Ohio Governor John
Kasich who's joining us here in the man
cave we'll come back also I want to see
if the governor will do a Jim Nantz
impersonation since we have a contest
today are you capable of a Jim Nance and
I'm not good no no I don't think so but
you don't that it sound exactly like him
it's just more of you welcome people on
the air at Augusta like well like you're
like sort of like we're here at Augusta
and I have to really act like I like
Nick Faldo hello friends we're
continuing with the Ohio governor
Republican presidential candidate John
Kasich joining us here in the man cave I
think you could stay here all day there
governor well we were talking about you
know your guy was in here talking about
Ohio State and I was talking about Woody
Hayes and woody you know people remember
him you know cuz slugging that guy a lot
of people think you know he was a
diabetic maybe he hadn't taken his
medication and cuz woody was loved
displayers his players loved him he
didn't take you know contracts they
tried to make a movie of his life he
told me he went out to Hollywood didn't
like it came home didn't want any of
that but I'll tell you a funny story and
this is kind of woody they have this
dedication of this Jesse Owens memorial
outside Ohio Stadium and I read about it
in the paper so I go up I figure
there'll be thousands of people I get
there it's raining there's like no one
there the president University woody the
Owens family couple other people they do
the dedications and I'm standing with
woody and mrs. Owens and I look at woody
I see coach a Jesse Owens greatest
athlete you'd ever seen huh what he goes
oh no no no Paul Warfield now that was a
great athlete receiver yeah that was
what do you know he was direct he was I
mean he was really something else
so so let's talk a little NBA so what do
you get a let me get a political
question in here is this has this been a
good year for politics I don't think so
I think it's been no I don't think it's
been good I think that people are just
like what is going on and that's not a
good thing I mean there's been there's
been very little about ish
using a whole lot about personalities
and name-calling and that's not the way
it you know if you want to go see if you
want to go see a good hockey game you
don't want to have a fight every five
minutes you know if you go to a car race
you know you don't want to just see a
crash all the time and it's like that's
what it's been just crashes and fights
and I don't think it's good I don't
think it's healthy maybe it's just what
we're going through people are unsettled
dan they think they're getting ripped
off and and some of this is being fed by
the media itself you know stirring
people up you know I remember that
segment they used to run about the guy
who was surfing in Hawaii who was on
food stamps you know so they take these
things and they blow them up and it just
infuriates people and you know and the
other thing is I tell you what's driving
people crazy their kids go to college
and then they get out and they can't
find a job and it just it they think the
system isn't working for them so there
is a a palpable frustration maybe an
anger but you have two ways of looking
at it either you go and you fix it where
all you do is drive people down into the
ditch farther
I don't think driving them into the
ditch farther is a good thing I think
it's better to tell them how you fix it
and to finish this sentence then we'll
do one NBA question lean one love - okay
no we'll do two who do if Donald Trump
is the Republican nominee he's not going
to be so I'm not even going there what
are you like a political reporter this
is what I get all day long I thought I
was in here to have why don't I stick a
couple in yeah yeah okay sneak one more
in he's not I don't believe he's gonna
be the nominee look here's what we're
going just for your edification I'm you
saying if he wasn't but you know what if
you okay what if you were my vice
president's pick if I were the nominee
what would you say yes yes I would would
you yes I would what I will serve well
what about all the dirt that will come
out of ESPN about you I think we could
still be that strong that we could get
past this and I got big hands - my hand
size is big if that matters is what
here's what we're going just so people
know we're gonna go to a convention it's
gonna be really something we haven't
seen since
like 1948 and and the delegates are
gonna get there and they're gonna figure
out who win who can win in the fall and
who could be President it's gonna be
very interesting and you're gonna spend
time talking about it even here because
it's gonna dominate the news and it's
gonna be something to see could you take
Trump No
physically could I take him physically
wrestling match well how about how about
in foul shooting oh I take yeah I would
take you without I wasn't that hot today
though how about golf he's pretty good
at golf yeah
have you played with him he he nudges
things a little bit you mean he's a
little foot way but you can't use a foot
wedge in golf I well he almost thinks
that he's presidential yeah before I got
you all this okay now hit me with a
couple NBA all right so what do you
think about the fact that these
old-timers are just talking about how
they would shut down Steph Curry and
this whole business of putting him down
what's wrong with these guys but its
territorial though governor that you
feel strongly about if I said you know
favorite football team you might say the
Buckeyes from 1970 fair even though
today's team's Alabama would be too I
think that they just they're proud of
their era yeah in what they did I do
think that the Bulls of the 90s would
beat Golden State I do think the Celtics
and Lakers from the 80s would beat
Golden State I just hate to see we
denigrate today because of what we saw
yesterday and that's not fair to the
Golden State Warriors yeah well you know
the interesting thing is I the question
it has to be asked about Golden State
because it's been written a little bit
about are they changing the very nature
of the game in other words you know you
think about the forward pass changed
football okay you think about I don't
know what you tell the live ball maybe
in baseball I don't know different
things that come along to change the
whole sport Fosbury flop remember that
guys jumped over the thing on a
different way yes I have the bull have
they have the Warriors fundamentally
changed the way that that the NBA works
but only if you have the players to be
able to play that way because you can
have guys who can jack it up from 35
feet it's they make it from 35 feet they
shot I think close to 80 percent in the
third quarter last night
I mean that's crazy for a jump shooting
team so they're changing the style but
you have to have the players to fit this
style I do have a Sports politic
question now you ready for this yeah can
we make Monday after the Super Bowl
a national holiday it should be I mean
there's no productivity whatsoever
exactly
widget you got our votes right there
yeah I think it should be I I'm gonna
I'm gonna take that under consideration
maybe I could get that done in the first
hundred days who's gonna who's gonna win
the Masters uh well I picked Jason day
but I think it's it's Rory or Spieth who
do you got uh you know what I I think
you're right I mean Jason well you know
he's still not out he stumbled yes you
know there's uh McIlroy has seems like
he's got the attitude I mean just how do
you know how about this guy D Shambo
what's the story mmm the amateur he's
chanting all of his clubs are the same
length yeah you know what I read today I
read they said asked him if he was
nervous he said no and this is really
interesting he said I'm not nervous
because I've been saved by grace you
know what that means that means he's got
a very strong faith personal faith if
that's what that means I read one line
today that that is what he said I've not
read it anywhere else but you know that
belief in a higher power that he's it's
sort of like me running for president
I've been very loose having a great time
because I'm carrying out a mission and
I'm saved by grace too so I think you
know when when everything isn't put into
achieving that thing that's right in
front of you but you have perspective it
gives you a chance to be to be loose at
this and you know and we get at
different ways but I think that was
interesting what I read and I just know
perspective makes it easier for you to
perform because your egos not caught in
the middle of it I'll leave you with
this question
would you rather shoot hoops with Steph
Curry or play golf with jordan Spieth
all right well that's a tough one boy
well if I'm president I could have both
have you played hoops against President
Obama no but I play golf with him I play
golf with Obama Biden and John Boehner
John Bain
invited me to this disc golf tournament
and Joe Biden was my partner and when we
showed up he had been like practice
he was like a horse that had been
lathered up I mean he was just dripping
in sweat and we and Boehner announced
--is that he's gonna have the president
as a partner and I'm gonna have Biden
and Biden's you know he's his reputation
is he's a very good golfer we were in
the cart on the first hole and then I
never saw him because he was using
because he was using his tree wood all
the time you know they couldn't find him
and I was at the convention and I said
you know Biden says this about
Republicans well he also says he's a
good golfer and I know that's not true
so why would I believe anything else
poor Joe you got you know what poor Joe
could you have Urban Meyer as you're
running me maybe no he's - well you know
a tasting about urban and all these
big-time football coaches man the focus
is unbelievable Dan they don't they see
there you talk about a horse with
blinders on they just run and everything
they do everything they have they
would've admires scare the hell out of
Putin I'll tell you something about
Meyer he's a very tough firm foe do you
know him
yeah we've had him on quite a few times
yeah I mean he is really a focused guy
isn't he
I saw him the other day II thought he
endorsed me you know I son the other day
I said how's it going he goes well I
don't have any players they all
graduated I said don't be talking to me
about that coach your life and you know
they'll be good again he's think about
the Big Ten in football right I mean for
a set for a second here you know there
was a theory that the Big Ten you know
dominated then everything went south
because of television and weather and
all that but when you think about the
Big Ten now and you think about Urban
Meyer the king of the coaches in the Big
Ten and you take Harbaugh you take Dan
Tony and those three guys in and of
themselves they're changing and of
course maybe in Wisconsin where they
always seem to have good teams they're
changing the nature of Northern Big Ten
football
I know it's interesting to see master
bra alphabetic they brought the SEC I
think in there all right I I have to go
you have to go I have to go you're more
than welcome to stay but I have to go
he's the Ohio Governor presidential
candidate and good luck we appreciate
was fun the Dan Patrick show we
day mornings on audience